good morning believe nation today's
messages give it your all over to you
little Wayne go I go hard in the paint
with this wraps real hard I take it real
seriously I take every single thing I do
every word every letter every sentence
every phrase every call every chorus and
verse every Bridge every intro every
outro
person
so if you have fun at me
then know that you get to fool me could
I get my all to my music this is really
important message for me I'm in Madrid
right now you can see kind of different
scenery behind me I was on the plane
today getting here and I realized just
how much of my time is going to be
taking up a communist events i'm
speaking at an event to help librarians
stay relevant because libraries are
expected to be extinct people predicting
their extinction and they need to stay
relevant and i'm here to help him do
that i left on a sunday night i get back
on a thursday night that's a good chunk
of the week gone I'm sitting there on
the plane thinking man I'm losing a ton
of time right kind of time that I could
be spending on other things and so for
it to be worth it for it to be worth
spending all this time away I have to
really have an impact right like the
people that I go and meet tomorrow and
the next day through my keno and through
the private sessions I'm gonna be having
it has to make a difference right it's
got to move them it's got to help them
go on and want to build a great library
be great librarians create the next
great library of Alexandra if I don't
have that kind of impact that I've
wasted my time and so it's a good
thought for me because it's totally on
me to bring it right when I come and do
my keynote I've got to bring it I've got
to have the excitement in managing the
passion to the point where they want to
take action they feel inspired to want
to do something to change their mindset
to change their environment change the
habits of change what they do and I got
to be given my all and so the more the
more I realize when I go away keeps
coming back to
that your time is limited right you do
not have a lot of time to make your
dreams happen and the best way to do it
is to start realizing that make every
minute count don't pack it in right
don't just mail it in and say ah you
know I'll do it tomorrow we'll do it
tomorrow do it right now whatever your
big plan is whatever your big dreams are
worried a big goal as soon as you have a
goal for yourself start taking immediate
action towards the attainment because
your time is going to be limited and
it's going to run out before you know it
so give it your all guys I'm excited I'm
going to see how tomorrow goes I'm super
pumped so question day today is what do
you do to give it your all leave in the
comments below I'll join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day getting you to believe
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events besa